you've done a lot of stuff in your
career you've produced a lot of stuff
you've directed a lot of stuff if
someone has actually never seen anything
you've done before what is the first
thing you'd like them starting with and
why the All-Star video by Smashmouth
sure did that that changed your life
well it's a little bit yeah I mean it's
just I don't know there's a through line
of of a dream where I came from a very
very average life and I dreamed about
things that were larger and more
exciting than my own life and I like
colorful magical big things cuz I was
living a hum drum existence so I tried
to bring that to the music and the music
videos and the commercials and the
movies and the television shows and uh
that's what you get so um speaking of
why I get to talk to you which is a
family switch I was watching the film
and I'm like wait a minute as I'm
watching that's Rivers wait a minute
this is Weezer yeah and so uh let's talk
about Weezer because I love the band and
how did you get them in the movie well
I've been stalking them ever since the
sweater song it was either 93 or '94 I'm
not not sure and secretly completely
obsessed with that band and they never
really let me in they sort of did all
their stuff with Spike Jones who's
infinitely cooler than I am and they
were wise to choose Spike over me but uh
I saw my opportunity and I grabbed it
I'm very pleased that we call River's
character name in the film lake so uh
for those of you paying a closer look
that you'll get a little pleasure out of
that that you see young Brady noon
screaming you know I'm trying Lake you
know right in the middle of it and
that's just something I enjoy my only
question is uh how much did you debate
actually have a Weezer song in the movie
because I don't think there is one in
the film or maybe I'm wrong well they
like the idea of covering a Christmas
song and he's just such a prolific
writer and you know he was coming back
from a two week silence Retreat that
Rivers CUA which I'd expect nothing else
from my rivers and uh yeah they were
happy to do that and they jammed all the
while with Ed Helms he was playing
guitar and occasionally banjo and doing
his thing and Jen was singing and uh the
fun that you feel in that scene in the
movie We Were having that much fun on
the day shooting it so um I think you
know I like talking about the editing
process uh so how did this film change
in the editing room in ways you didn't
expect going in I think people
underestimate how hard it is to find
comedy you as an afficionado of editing
do know that um releasing the joke and
getting to the place where people
overtly laugh is a matter of frames in
the editorial process and it's ironic
because if you look at uh the comedians
most comedians are great dramatic actors
rarely are dramatic actors funny and
comedy doesn't get a lot of respect in
our town and I think it's one of the
most difficult things to achieve so the
editorial process has everything to do
with finding where the joke is and
getting to the funny and hopefully there
were a few Giggles along the way with
this one yeah you it's funny you
mentioned that because with when it
comes to the award season everyone just
forgets about comedies and how difficult
they are to actually pull off it's like
they're like oh those are easy but it's
only the dramatic that we can applaud
yeah I mean I think it's going to be
curious when we get the best picture nod
over May
December yes
absolutely like wait a minute don't tell
Natalie right so uh they've obviously
been a lot of body switch movies in the
past when you're getting ready to film
this are you watching those or are you
purposely avoiding them no I devour all
of them and the funny thing is and I ask
you as a film huge film fan we both are
can you name one you don't like they're
all pretty good some better than others
but they're all pretty dog G good and
I'm really big into yungi and archetypes
and I got to believe there's just
something deep down in the psyche of us
as human beings where we're obsessed
with the idea of what it's like to walk
a mile in each other's shoes and our
contribution to that was a six-way
switch baby dog mom daughter dad son and
hopefully that adds a Twist of
originality and makes it all worthwhile
on that note sir I mean this sincerely I
really hope it's a huge hit for you and
great to see you you as
well